Now, the important thing to understand to be able to figure this out here
is that if the Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment
then a shortest path from A to B that visits all vertices can visit each of these vertices
by basically paying just one extra edge.
Instead of going this way, we have to go this way exactly once for each clause.
The length of the shortest path from A to B that visits all vertices
is the same as the shortest path from A to B that does not visit the clause vertices plus m
because we have to pay one extra edge for each clause vertex that we visit here.
It's something plus m and we know that
there is a path between A and B that visits each vertex exactly once,
and so, the path length from A to B is almost the same as the number of vertices,
it's just one less, so you can see this here in the example.
If I have two vertices then the shortest path would mean those vertices is one so one less
If I go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 vertices then the path has length four and so on.
What we have here is 5n + 3 mn +1 and then we have to add m.
Our total here is 5m + 3mn +1. And now, we are almost done.
We have shown that if the Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment
then the length of the shortest path from A to B that visits all vertices has length 5n + m + 3mn +1
Where n is the number of variables and m is the number of clauses.
Now, we also have to show the other direction of course.
If there is a shortest path between A and B of length 5n + m + 3mn +1
then each clause in the Boolean Formula can be satisfied.
We have a satisfying assignment.
Right now, we have shown that if the Boolean formula is satisfied
then we have a path of this length and now, we need to show the other direction as well of course.
If we have a path of this length then the Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment.
Why do we need to show those two directions?
That is because the requirement for reduction is that our new instance that we constructed here
is a yes instance if and only if this Boolean formula up here has a satisfying assignment
Right now, we have shown the if and now, we have to show the only if,
but this is actually quite easy because if we know that there is a path
between A and B of this length here then we already know
that each vertex is visited exactly once because this is the bear minimum of a tour between A and B
given this many vertices.
Secondly, we know that the tour will correspond to a variable assignment
It will correspond to an assignment of true and false to these vertices here
because otherwise we would visit a city more than once.
We've already shown that and finally, we have also shown that each clause can be satisfied
because we can only visit a vertex down here like that with paying just one extra edge
if the assignment up here corresponds to a satisfying assignment.
And now, we are almost done in showing that shortest tour is NP complete.
I don't know if you noticed, but there is one small detail missing
Right now, we are only going from A to B and we are asking for the shortest path from A to B.
We are not asking for shortest tour yet and that is actually quite easy to fix.
We'll just remove this vertex B here and make this edge very, very, very, very long over here
and then it's not the length of the shortest path from A to B anymore,
but it's the length of the shortest tour.
And of course, that length is only true if and only if the Boolean formula is satisfiable
And we're done. We have reduced SAT to a shortest tour.
We have shown that shortest tour is in NP.
So, now, our final conclusion this problem here is NP-complete
Of course, it's a bit ironic that showing that a problem such as shortest tour is NP complete
can sometimes feel like solving an NP complete problem in itself.
That's why I would now like to show you how to even further simplify that problem is NP complete.